à moi après les battles tu sors ton
premier single un homme de goût c'est un
énorme carton
et ouais tu vas tu connais un homme
debout et il paraît que le succès est
venu tellement vite que t'es pas passé
loin du burn out c'est ce qu'on avait
dit que j'étais en plein dedans trait
comtois monsieur ramasser la gueule
comme en ski libre à supporter les
hôtels de luxe j'ai pas supporté voilà
ce monde ces trucs un peu étranger qui
n'était pas le mien tout simplement tu
vois ce prix c'est à la réunion que je
suis vraiment parti en la 3g pas
supporter mais sur quoi tu avais envie
coulthard été ou pas ouais neiger j'ai
parfois envie d'arrêter encore
aujourd'hui pourquoi ce pas parce que
c'est compliqué parce que c'est pas rien
parce que faute sur red bull futur est
présentable couture bien par les
voitures faire les choses que tu vois et
puis parfois j'ai alors que je suis je
fais mais je fais pas attention je suis
comme je suis je suis je fais pas de
manière avec les réseaux sociaux mais il
s'est gardé mickey mouse et je suis pas
chez moi quoi c'est pas mon truc quoi je
connais personne j'ai l'impression que
tu vas au milieu c'était sûr loin de ma
campagne quoi tu vois c'est ça après
maintenant c'est cool maintenant je suis
content je me suis habitué je rigole
j'ai plus peur de vous
[Rires]
mais
c'est extrêmement beau site est rare
qu'un artiste voilà verbalise ses
fragilités et 10 voilà moi je découvre
le succès et c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas évident à vivre et je me le
prends le mur et moi j'adore j'adore il
jouera contre la corrosion puis je suis
sûr qu'il y en a plein qui ont osé ça et
c'est pour ça qu'on les aime bah oui et
c'est normal qu'on regarde le succès
comme ça qui est aussi soudain c'est
vrai que ça doit faire beaucoup en fait
tu vois ton matois c'est un autre c'est
un outil parce que c'est avec toi tu as
toujours connu la célébrité mine de rien
tant que ça mais non mais c'est vrai je
vois très bien ce que tu veux dire c'est
sûr il faut faire attention
j'ai eu la chance de mon disque m mon
premier disque marché très fort mais
j'avais 35 ans et donc j'étais déjà
assez mûri revoir la taxe sur les hauts
revenus à tout ça et c'est sûr que
l'essentiel ça reste toujours voilà les
valeurs
les vrais amis ce qu'on aime nos
passions la famille etc
michou toi tu as peur parce que tu es
très jeunes là tu vas faire 18 ans
d'ailleurs on a des images de honte a
suivi pour ton anniversaire avec vous
est-ce que tu as peur de plus tard où tu
te dis ouais on imagine dans deux ans ça
s'arrête ou pas du tout ce qu'à
apprendre et tu dis je veux qu'ils font
en vrai où elle a un vrai champlain dans
juge je kiffe et on verra par la suite
ce qui arrivera mais pour l'instant je
suis en plein dedans donc répond grossi
mais des sous de côté un métal mans
j'avais peur que tu étais achète une
maison achetée maison bas et attend déjà
signé l'immédiat il achète une paire de
baskets
on le voit on l'a vu dans le magnéto eux
ils l'ont dit c'est vrai que avec ce que
tu fais le nom de vue etc tu gagne
énormément dessous dim ce que ça te fait
tourner la tête ou pas c'est quoi c'est
quoi le mine de rien c'est vrai qu'on se
rend pas compte nous mais l' ordre
d'idées voilà de deux tubes pénible ces
chats sachez que sinon on se rend pas
compte de ce que ça peut être c'est une
île 20000 euros trop timide par tous
alors je te demande pas parce que non
mais je vous dis c'est ça peut être
énorme
mais ce nul laisse tes parents tu t'es
peut-être tes parents tu essaies de
toute la famille à nos frères et soeurs
ouais vraiment carrément j'essaye
d'offrir de faire plaisir et c'est aussi
la famille qui m'aide à gérer tout ça
garder les pieds sur terre